i'm charlotte nice to meet you for some
leaseholders a glimmer of hope those
living in mid-rise buildings could have
help covering the cost of removing
dangerous cladding
so
very simply it's the cladding at the top
the grey panels at the top just here
there at the top but leaseholder liam
spender wants to see the details the
toll of this has been enormous and the
announcement doesn't stop us uh it's the
announcement's only a signpost
to what's what's coming nothing will
change
immediately and and we need to act on
this it's already been four and a half
years more than four and a half years
a letter seen by sky news shows that
housing secretary michael gove will
announce that leasehold is in buildings
between 11 and 18 meters tall will no
longer have to take out loans to fix
flammable cladding instead developers
will be asked to make voluntary
contributions to cover the work costing
up to four billion pounds if they're
reluctant developers can be threatened
with legal action or tax but the plans
only cover cladding when many buildings
have other fire safety problems
mp daisy cooper has been a vocal
supporter of leaseholders she says the
government needs to go further
it sounds like the government wants
developers to voluntarily give up to
four billion pounds but it's refusing to
introduce any mechanisms to enforce
that particular measure and it's also
incredibly worrying that the government
is simply saying that this money can
only be used for cladding when we know
that cladding is not the only problem
many buildings here in some albums but
around the country have other building
safety issues to do with fire breaks and
insulation and balconies and all sorts
of other issues and the government has
got to step up and find a comprehensive
solution because innocent leaseholders
are stuck in a living nightmare day in
day out and the government needs to step
up and make sure that it's the polluters
that have to pay well leaseholders
welcome this announcement there's still
so many areas that are unclear and while
making the pollute of pay is good in
principle it will take time and time is
not what many leaseholders have as they
face imminent rising costs of service
charge bills and insurance premiums
building safety experts say there's lots
of questions to be answered
there are significant gaps for the
potentially up to a million blocks that
are below 11 meters in height that
aren't mentioned
that have fire safety issues or building
safety issues
and the
skepticism that we have about whether
the industry will come forward and
provide the voluntary contributions that
make up the four billion pounds of
additional funding and if they don't
come forward and make those voluntary
contributions
that money needs to be found from the
department of housing's budget
and that will have consequences for
other housing projects so while this
latest announcement is a step forward
it's by no means a solution for the
hundreds of thousands of leaseholders
trapped in unsafe homes charlotte lomas
sky news